my friend Gotti tab is is on Skype right
now he's an Israeli historian an author
he's a screenwriter he's a political
commentator I did a few events with him
when we were in Israel not too long ago
uh he's been
battling uh a lot of the the sort of
crazy leftism that's deeply connected to
the backwards which is why you have Gaye
for Palestine which is very different
than Palestine for Gaye and all of the
confusion around all of this I I I don't
even know how to do this properly uh
Gotti Gotti you there
yeah yes I am thank you for your strong
words Dave they come from the heart and
and we can see them so thanks I hope I
did something that could make a few of
you guys proud um I don't know just tell
me what's going on you're you're in Tel
a at the moment just just take it away
as I was listening to you there were uh
interceptions by Iron Dome U I'm not
sure if above my house or somewhere
around the outskirts of Tel Aviv my cats
are sitting here because they're scared
from these explosions but what is
happening in Tel Aviv is is nothing what
we've seen in in in the south of Israel
are atrocities and and images that we
haven't seen since the Holocaust and I'm
glad you mentioned that these barbarians
took a holocaust Survivor an 85 year-old
Holocaust Survivor as a hostage imagine
this women this woman has been I don't
know how many sleepless nights from
post- trauma in aitz and now she's back
in the hands of those
anti-semitic neo-nazis and it's it's
Unthinkable and you see those you see
those images slaughtering children it's
we haven't we came to this country
saying never again never again and I
don't
know what existential apology the
universe can make to this woman who is
now back in the hands of of of those
barbarians so so first of all there's
there's shock here and and we're just
beginning to understand what is going on
and everybody was heartwarming by by uh
President Biden's uh warm words but we
we don't we shouldn't forget that this
has been brewing for a long time this is
an Iranian operation and the United
States has just given them6 billion
you've seen probably the videos of the
high-tech drones that they've used in
this infiltration and so these are the
sour fruits of two terribly misguided
Democratic administrations with one
short uh break for Donald Trump and you
need to see the geopolitical uh picture
the what was in the making now is a
peace between Saudi Arabia and Israel
and what we are seeing now is Iran
strategically sacrificing the interests
of the Palestinian people in order to
break this new alignment which is
threatening its strategic interests in
the region because obviously the the the
Palestinian people I don't I have
nothing to say in their favor now they
voted for Hamas H you know if if if you
want to understand the mentality of a
people what who are the heroes on the
names of whom they call schools and
squares and streets you are a hero for
the Palestinian people if you kill
enough Jews that's the one thing that
makes you a hero so we're not on the
road to any peace and and the Iranians
are trying to turn the Palestinians into
a wedge now between Israel and Saudi
Arabia and and they're doing it in their
in this in this barbaric way so we have
Hamas on the south and we have Iran's
other arm on the northala and we have
them trying to Circle us with their
proxies yeah and and I hope that some of
my explanation
again I was doing it sort of off the top
of my head
and I don't even know what to say
exactly but right right before we
started uh Brock my social media guy
mentioned to me that you know when I saw
you just a few days later back in may we
went up to the north and we looked at
you know one of the Hezbollah Towers
that's literally just like feet away
from the Israeli border and it's like if
the Israelis weren't there they would
gladly jump over the other side but the
Hezbollah doesn't fear that the Israelis
out of nowhere are just going to attack
them like the asymmetry of the thing is
backwards but he showed it to because it
looks like the tower has now been
destroyed because they're shooting
Rockets over that but I don't even want
to get lost that can you just talk about
the human part of what's going on I mean
I I have no doubt that you know people
that have have probably been killed
Andor kidnapped uh just the human part
of and it does it feel like it's at
least a little more controll within the
borders at the moment or or something a
a little more control they've not they
they've not uh completely taken control
of the situation and what happened I
think is that we were not expecting this
infiltration of kibuts of private homes
what they did is they we we don't yet
know how they how they neutralized all
the electronic surveillance apparatuses
but what they did and they plan to do is
to enter civilian settlements like
kibuts overwhelm the guards at the
entrance and then go from house to house
to slaughter people sparing no one and
the videos are so atrocious you you
can't you can't show them on your show
Da you can't you can't even put them on
social media some of them are this is
this is a a snuff pornography of of of
evil and and you I don't want to start
describing them but but people in Israel
have lost their sense of security and so
now we're talking about uh giving arms
to civilians and the minister of
national security has now loosened our
gun laws usually we have a lot of guns
you know a lot of people are in res
deserve service and we have a lot of
guns but they are not enough and if we
are going if if indeed we are going to a
two front War withis balat to we have a
only a limited uh size for an army and
we are going to have to massively arm
ourselves because the the the scary
thing with this is you don't know where
it will come from what do you make of
sort of the existential misunderstanding
of Israel and the history of the Jews
and again I tried to do some basic
simple history there but like the amount
of stupidity and ignorance that is
flaunted everywhere and that MSNBC
constantly shows this map of how
Palestine has disappeared over the years
even though there was never a country
called Palestine or a people known as
Palestinians etc etc um the the average
Israeli must walk around with that
knowing that it it in some ways it does
not matter we just have to survive and
they will lie about us and it just is
what it is first of all the we have a
woke contingent in our Elites too and
you and I have been fighting basically
the same war in our separate countries
but note that what they've managed to do
over the years is turn the language of
Human Rights into the new vehicle of
anti-Semitism now human rights
organizations are demonizing Israel in
the language of Human Rights so if if
you're in historian and you look back at
history then they've been saying for
decades that Jews have Slaughter been
slaughtering Christian kids for our
matot in Passover and now they use human
rights organizations in order to portray
the Jewish State as a murderer of
children while we have murderers of
children on the other side look as
Benjamin Nan said so clearly we protect
our women and children with rockets they
protect their Rockets with women and
children and it's time we stopped
flinching that this blood is on their
hands and we are trying to play
a in in an ultra moral um way of
behavior in a conflict where we are
facing barbarians with no moral Scruples
at all and we should in in the very
least H give the right impression that
we this time around we are not going to
stop because of some Goldstone report
that turns out to be fake and full of
full of blood lials in the language of
Human
Rights I don't even know what what else
to ask you is there is there anything
else you want to say for now I mean
obviously I'll have you on whenever you
want to come back on and I'll I'll
gladly have anyone that you think I
should have on and all of that but I I
I'll be glad to be to be back and you're
doing uh great work I think the work
that that that people should do on on on
on your side in the United States is
don't let the Biden Administration cheat
you about Iran there strengthening Iran
they're stepping over Israel's Head
they're doing it in a Sly way they've
loosened all the sanctions on this state
that's that has a religious goal of
erasing the Jewish people from the face
of the Earth and they're playing this
game it started with the Obama
Administration it goes on with the Biden
Administration we still know there are
Iranian spies inside this Administration
and it's it's appeasing the worst Force
ever so this is a chamberlan mistake and
Americans should point it out got I
thank you for your time I will say a
prayer for you I know that that
literally millions of Americans and and
more than that all over the world are
doing just that and uh I mean it anytime
I'm deeply touched Dave thank you for
all the good work that you're
doing